my name's lauren scott and in my humble
opinion
i think that social media is changing
the ways both in which we experience the
emotions of other people and how we
express our emotions publicly
[Music]
i think the main thing you have to think
about social media is that our emotions
are a valuable resource
so it behooves the people who are
designing social media networks such as
twitter
facebook to make our emotions as clearly
obvious and evident to others as
possible so you may have noticed on
facebook one of the first
questions you're greeted with is what's
on your mind
a couple of years ago to notice sort of
a comedy of errors that's brewing
in our emotional landscape with social
media so in the same year
facebook finally rolled out its six
reaction features so instead of just
simply liking things
that your friends have posted you could
add the heart or the
sad face or the angry face mark
zuckerberg at the time
said what people want to do is express
empathy
but this empathy was again channeled
into discrete
a discrete set of emotions that weren't
sort of limitless
or boundless now why this is a funny
sort of irony
is that in that same year a robot was
released onto the market
by a company called hanson robotics and
the robot was called pepper
and robots such as these were being
trained to recognize
and i quote 62 different facial and
neck architectural features of humans so
while the robots were learning 62
different ways
to recognize us and to be able to tell
what emotions we were feeling
we were being allowed a range of six
emotions on social media
i'm sure you've noticed this too that on
social media we're sort of
asked to experience two completely
different kinds of emotions one after
the other
so on your timeline you may see that
your best friend's child is sort of
toddling around on the carpet you may
feel the warmth
and excitement of that and then the next
post could be something about
7 000 killed an earthquake the way that
the timeline and the news feeds are
structured
i really have no emotional consistency
at all so we're often being jerked
in in our effective responses from one
emotion to the next quite quickly and i
think
this century will be about how do we
cope with
these quick gear changes in our
emotional lives
uh where people's sort of internal
landscapes are being
altered very very radically from one
emotion to the next
[Music]
really the name of the game in social
media commerce is to make
your time on the site as maximum as
possible
so a lot of the way that the websites
are designed to encourage you to stay on
it
to return to it and how they do that is
to create quite sort of addictive
little algorithms such as there's one
where um
on twitter there's a there's a bit of a
delay before the how many notifications
you have come up and there's that
there's a very human basic response
there
uh where we wait to see something that's
variable and changing
we get a little hit of dopamine when
there's a sort of a category of data
that's changing that we can monitor
so there's that brief moment of
excitement that we all know even when
we're just checking an email
how many new emails do i have how many
notifications and that little pause
encourages uh encourages us that sort of
sense of anticipation that is then
rewarded
when we see the actual number so in this
way social media is sort of
trying to tap in to very fundamental
things about how our
psychologies work and our emotional
lives are structured
thanks for watching if you enjoyed that
be sure to check out these videos next
and if you haven't already
hit the subscribe button and click the
bell to get a notification each time we
upload a new video